في يومها العالمي العالم كله بيحتفل في
المراه وبنات رونالدو بيتكلموا عربي هو
تفاعلكم يعرفكم على
المنصه اللي خلطت التعليم والترفيه اهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
محتفل العالم في الثامن من مارس اليوم
بمناسبه غاليه على قلب الكل يوم المراه
العالمي واللي اسمها اشتاقيتو بكل اللغات
ماليه المنصات ترند في جميع الدول احتفاءا
بانجازاتها على جميع الاصعده فكل عام وانا
وكل نساء العالم بالف خير وكل عام والنساء
العالم مشرقين ومزدهرين ومن نجاح لنجاح في
تفاعلكم طبعا مو غايب عن بالنا ابدا كم من
الصعوبات والمعوقات والازمات اللي لسه
بتعانيها المراه حول العالم وجزء اساسي من
قضايانا في البرنامج هنا هو انه مسلط
الضوء عليها لكن اليوم حابين نحتفل ونحتفل
بس يعني ما نتكلم عن صعوبات ومئاسي في يوم
المراه العالمي كالعاده اول المحتفلين كان
جوجل اللي غير شعاره مثل ما شايفين واحتفى
بانجازات المراه ودورها في كل مكان وزمان
كام كعامله كممرضه كسياسيه وغيرها من
المهن ومثل كل عام في شعار بيكون خاص بيوم
المراه والشعار بيكون وراء قصه وهدف وهذه
السنه اطلقت الامم المتحده شعار اشراك
الجميع رقميا الابتكار والتقنيه لتحقيق
المساواه بين الجنسين
الامم المتحده قالت انها اختارت هذا
العنوان للاحتفال السنه لانه رغم اهميه
الانترنت في العالم وانتشاره لكن لسه في
37% من نساء العالم ما بيستخدموه وستات
اقل من الرجال ب 259 مليون بيستخدموا
الانترنت هذه الفروقات الامم المتحده
سمتها فجوه رقميه بين الرجال والنساء
وعليه قررت ان السنه يكون الاحتفال عن
طريق الدعوه لاشراك المراه اكثر في هذا
المجال سواء في التعليم او تطوير المهارات
او العمل في المجالات التكنولوجيه وكان
نشر الموقع رساله من الامين العام انطونيو
اللي قال انه الاستثمار في المراه بينهض
بجميع الناس
والدول حتى والبلدان كافه
اما للي حابب يعرف ايش هي اصلا قصه يوم
المراه العالمي فالقصه ترجع لي 8 مارس عام
1856 لما طلعت الالاف من النساء في شوارع
مدينه نيويورك للاحتجاج على الظروف اللا
انسانيه اللي بينجبروا على العمل فيها وتم
تفيقها من قبل الشرطه في عام 1908 في نفس
التاريخ 8 مارس طلعت الالاف من عاملات
النسيج للتظاهر في شوارع نيويورك وطالبنا
وقتها بتخفيض ساعات العمل ووقف تشغيل
الاطفال ومنح النساء حق الاقتراع وتم
الاحتفال لاول مره بيوم المراه العالمي في
8 مارس
1909 في امريكا وكان اسمه اليوم القومي
للمراه في الولايات المتحده تذكيرا
بالاحتجاجات النسويه السابقه في نيويورك
ومن بعدها وصل الى اوروبا في 1911 وتم
تبني هذا اليوم
رسمي للاحتفال بانجازات المراه
عام 1977 بعد اعتماده من قبل الامم
المتحده وفي عدد من الدول بيكون فيها هذا
اليوم عطله رسميه للمراه مثل روسيا والصين
واوكرانيا وفيتنام
في نهايه احتفالنا بيوم المراه العالمي
اسمحوا لنا بتفاعلكم واحنا على فكره يعني
فريق نسائي بامتياز انه نقول كلمه يعني
واقفه في حلوقنا مؤخرا نقصد يعني في اخر
كم سنه صايرين نسمع اصوات رجاليه كثير
بتعترض على الاحتفالات بيوم المراه وشايفه
انه يعني
في الاعلام انه ما بنتكلم عن الرجال
جوسيين بس نحتفي بالمراه طيب لكل الرجال
من هؤلاء بنقول انه يا جماعه ترى مو
مشكلتنا انه انتم ما بتحتفلوا بيومكم
العالمي وما بتعملوا احتفاليات ومناسبات
وايفنتات ترى لكم يوم عالمي
ابشركمبر بس اذا انتم مو عارفين عنه ما
بتحتفلوا فيه احنا ايش بنسوي ما نحتفل
بنفسنا الى ان تحتفلوا بنفسكم انتم اهو
احنا الان بلغناكم للي ما يعرف ترى يومكم
العالم يا رجال في 19 نوفمبر اعملوا
احتفاليه بتشتغلوا عليه خلو الامم المتحده
تعترف فيه واحنا وعد علينا نتكلم عنه
ونغطي او يمكن لا
يبدو ان اسره اللعب البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو تاقلموا بشكل سريع في السعوديه
وهذا الشيء شفناه في ستوريه شريكته
جورجينا اللي مو بس جالسه تشارك مع الناس
انشطتها وجولاتها في السعوديه لكن امس
كمان طلعت لنا او طلعت لنا في ستورياتها
بناتها هي وكريستيانو والانا وايفا وهم
بيغنوا وبيتكلموا بالعربي ويبدو انك كانت
بتستعين بجوجل علشان تفهم ايش بيقولوا
وتصلح لهم كمان خلينا نشوف المقطع
الثلاثاء الاربعاء الخميس الجمعه
[موسيقى]
ما اسرتي
احبتي احب لامي الجمعه
الثلاثاء الاربعاء الخميس الجمعه
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله يعني مخارج الحروف مزبوطه
والجيم يعني كتير ناس تفاعلت مع المقطع
وعلقت على الموضوع هذا كمان نذكره بالشبه
بين اللغه البرتغاليه والعربيه في مخارج
كثير احرف واللي يبدو مسهل على بنات
رونالدو العربي
التعليم بعيدا عن الاسلوب التقليدي
والرتابه والملل نقدر نقول انه شيء مو سهل
منصه جديده دخلت هذا العالم وللان عليها
اقبال كبير من وقت انطلقتها هي اول منصه
تعليميه ترفيهيه في الشرق الاوسط وجمال
افريقيا بتقدم دورات خلينا نقول انها
حصريه في جميع المجالات وعلى يد ابرز
المشاهير وبتقدم المعلومات حتى والخبرات
هذه بطريقه بتجمع بين الترفيه والتعليم في
نفس الوقت للان صار متاح على المنصه دروس
مع الصحفي الكبير ومديرنا في العربيه
السابقا الاستاذ الكبير عبد الرحمن الراشد
والمخرجه نادين لبكي والسنرست تامر حبيب
وعارضه الازياء العالميه نور عريضه
انا عشت وعملت تقريبا خمس سلاثين سنه في
الاعلام بشكل عام اعتقد هذه من اعظم المهن
ومن اجملها مدارس مختلفه في صناعه السينما
ومدارس مختلفه في الاخراج علشان تكتب اي
سيناريو في الدنيا هو الفكره مصدر الفكره
لا حصر له ولا عدد ابهر نفسك اول واحد
هتقصد طوب الارض فهي العمل كله بس كانهن
راقصين عم يرقصوا حوالي هالممثلين
في الوقت قدامكم
[موسيقى]
تجاربي مختلفه
مرحبا انا نادين لبكى وهيدي تجربتي على
ازيكم انا
تامر دي تجربتي
[موسيقى]
معنا في الاستوديو طارق الجندي المؤسس
والرئيس التنفيذي لمنصه
اهلين طارق كيف حالك
اشرح لنا اذا تقدر يعني بطريقه كذا مختصره
للي ابدا يعني ما له علاقه بهذه الامور
ايش
برضو حركه كويسه حركه مدروسه اعطوا له عشر
دقايق زياده يا جماعه
وكل الصبايا بعيد
منصه التعليم هي الاولى من نوعها بمنطقه
الشرق الاوسط
تعليم الترفيه او ما يقال يصطلح عليه
اطلقت المنصه مؤخرا بشهر ايلول العام
الماضي بتقدم محتوى اليوم باللغه العربيه
وقريبا جدا بلغات مختلفه هالمحتوى هو
عباره عن دورات تدريبيه اونلاين نختلف عن
باقي المنصات انه في منصات زيها قريبه
منها مشهوره جدا
حملات كبيره على الانترنت الاجنبيه يعني
نختلف عنهم انه نحن المعرفه ما بنقدمها
باسلوب اكاديمي فقط نحن بندمج المحتوى
المعرفي مع التوثيق الاكاديمي مع الترفيه
اسالينا كيف ممكن هالمعادله هالمعادله يتم
تحقيقها لانه نتعاون مع ابرز المدربين
المدربين هم عباره عن اعظم العقول في
المنطقه وفي العالم هم ايقونات الابداع هم
مشاهير هم شخصيات بارزه ناجحين في
مجالاتهم بيقدمونا خبرتهم بتعلم من
تجاربهم الناجحه بمختلف المجالات باسلوب
بسيط وممتع
مثلا لو انا بتفرج مثلا انه كيف من واحد
مثلا يقول لك انه طيب اوكي انا حتفرج بس
كيف اتعلم من هذا الشيء مثلا ممكن يسلي لي
وقتي اوكي بس كيف حتعلم هلا اليوم الكورس
او الدوره التدريبيه هي عباره عن ثلاث
الاربع ساعات كل كورس مقسم لعشرين درس كل
درس
عباره عن فيديو هالفيديو بتم انتاجه
بمعايير سينمائيه عاليه الجوده مدتها من
عشر دقايق
غير هالدروس نحنا بنقدم اساليب بنقدم
ورشات عمل تدار دراسه حاله تدرس وتدار من
قبل مدربين انفسهم سالتيني انه شو ممكن
اتعلم نحن بندمج من خلال هالمنصه مش فقط
يعني نقدم اساليب عمليه ومنقدم مهارات
اساسيه للنجاح في رقم واحد رقم اثنين
منقدم بالاشتراك مع المدربين اللي معنا
منقدم خبرات شخصيه وقصص ملهمه
لنجاحات
للمصاعب المروريه للدروس حتى الاخطاء حتى
تجنبها كل المشتركين وكل مدرب كمان بيعمل
مثل بيقدم مثال عن تجرب العمل من خلال كيس
والاهم من هيك ممكن بعد ما يخلص اي شخص
الكورس يحس حاله انه هو يتعرف على طرق
جديده لتنويع مصادر دخله بالمهنه هو اللي
بيشتغل فيها ففي فرصه انه حتى يفكر في
الموضوع من ناحيه عمل او انه كيف يضيف
عمله ودخله مئه بالمئه هي صارت
تعليم الاكاديمي
ما بدي اقول انتهى بدي اقول انا انه بده
رديف رديف يكون اعتماد على قصص واقعيه من
الواقع لاشخاص نجحوا في مجالاتهم وكيفيه
نقل خبرات لهم انت يعني منقيين يعني اسامي
جدا كبيره كيف بتعتمدوا الاسامي اللي
بتختاروها الاسامي نعتمدها اول شيء حسب
المجالات
الافضل في كل مجاله نعتمد على معادله ما
بين الكونتن والبابوليريتي شو معنى
الشعبيه والمحتوى لازم في يعني شعر لازم
يكون شعبيه وعنده كمان محتوى قوي جدا مدرب
العربيه هائله ولكن محتوى ضعيف ما بساعد
المنصه والعكس صحيح طبعا كل المدربين
تعاملنا معهم باساميهم الكبيره التقينا
معهم على هدف الهدف هو التفاعل مع المجتمع
هو اعطاء الفرصه لجميع المشتركين انه
يتعلموا خبرات واقعيه
بضيفوها لتعلموه بالكتب وتعلموهج تعليميه
يعني مو بس انه كتابه السيناريو او
الاعلام او الاخراج افترض عندكم
الاعمال رياده الاعمال الاستثمار الرياضه
الفن التمثيل الجيمنج
اي موضوع يخطر على بالك
سنتطرق له طبعا بكل في دراسه لاحتياجات
احتياجات
الجمهور الاحتياجات المشتركين بكل بلد
مثلا السعوديه شو هي اكثر ثلاث مواضيع
مهمه بالنسبه لهم الامارات مصر والى اخره
الى اخره
منصتنا فيها من الذكاء الاصطناعي ما
يؤهلنا بنقدر كمان ندرس بنسميه واحتياجات
الجمهور من مشاركتهم تفاعلهم كيفيه تعطيهم
مع الدورات المقدمه سؤال سريع كيف اقنعت
عبد الرحمن الراشد يمكن هو واحد من اصعب
الاسباب لا يمكن اقناعها وطبعا احنا حزين
لانه استاذنا وحبيبنا وكل شيء يعني اول
شيء
انك تعطي للمجتمع نعطي للمجتمع ترد
للمجتمع جزء من تعلمناه منه والاستاذ عبد
الرحمن كمان حابب هالخبرات انه ينقلها
للاجيال القادمه نحن اليوم عنا هدفين
رئيسيين والتقينا فيه مع استاذ عبد الرحمن
تعليم والمعرفه والاقتصاد المعرفي هي اساس
تطور اي مجتمع او اي شعب فالهدفين اول شيء
انه ايصال المعرفي الاكبر عدد ممكن من
الاشخاص بشكل مبتكر عن طريق خلق
نموذج تعليمي يواكب عفوا يواكب العصر
وكمان بواكب طريقه تفكير الاجيال الجديده
نغم مع اسلوب حياتهم انا بتفرج انا كيف
اقدر اشوف هذه الاشياء هل في اشتراك في
اشي الطريقه طبعا نحن اليوم عنا اشتراكات
متعدده اشتراك شهري في اشتراك سنوي ممكن
تشتركي بس بالكورس اللي انت بتحبيه لماذا
الحياه
كيف ممكن يعني توصل للمنصه بعدين
على اجهزه الموبايل
الاشتراكات مختلفه اسعارها حسب البلد
وطبعا حسب اذا شهري او سنوي او اذا بس
لدوره تدريبيه معين لمن الان انتو بادئين
وبادئين بهذه الاسماء الكبيره ايش نتوقع
في الفتره القادمه ممكن تكونوا حتضيفوا
للمنصه او نشوف تنويع المجالات موعد
الجميع باسامي بحبوها بحبوا يتعلموا منها
وكمان
المشتركين حيكون في عنا
تفاعل اكثر ما بين المتلقي وبين المدرب عن
طريق اما لايف ايفانس
وكانه يعني اشياء اون لاين
الافتراضيا او واقعيا
يعني الواحد ممكن يخطر على باله لما تجد
كلمه واحد من هذه الاسماء حيقول لك مثلا
ابغى مبلغ مهول علشان اقدم هذا الكورس
تدفعه قديش للناس اولا اكيد في اطار
تعاقدي يعني بيني وبينهم وثانيا اكيد اكيد
ما تفاصيل
[ضحك]
خلاص يعني بعدين تحت الهواء
ممكن تحسن
بنشكرك جدا وبتمنى لك التوفيق فيه المنصه
كان معنا في الاستوديو طارق الجندي المؤسس
والرئيس التنفيذي لمنصه ماين موفيز شكرا
لك شكرا
مشاهدينا وصلنا لختام حلقتنا اليوم انا
عود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله بكره الخميس
اكدوا لي بس الخميس الونيس اجمل ايام
الاسبوع في امان الله
[موسيقى]